hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast a case study for
immunotherapies and targeted therapies
and Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots and
I'll be a moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
groups the leading scientific social
network site and provider of virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning for more
information please visit www have a few
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event we can submit questions
by typing them in the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of a
presentation window we'll try to get to
as many of your questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide link if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the Q&A button
lower left will now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Louise Perkins dr.
Perkins joined the melanoma Research
Alliance as chief science officer in
2013 where she is responsible for the
development and implementation of the
mrs scientific strategy to eliminate
suffering and death to the melanoma for
interest center on translational
research including genomics drug
discovery and advancement of novel
therapeutic approaches prior to joining
the MRA she was chief scientific officer
the multiple myeloma Research Foundation
for five years following a 16 year
research career at two major
pharmaceutical companies for more
information on dr. Perkins experience
please click on her name I will now turn
it over to dr. Perkins for her
presentation
Thank You Brenda hello everyone as
Brenda said I'm Louise Perkins I'm the
chief science officer at the melanoma
Research Alliance it's my pleasure today
to give you this overview of melanoma
which really is a case study for
immunotherapies and targeted therapies
before we get started I wanted to just
spend a few minutes providing you a
short introduction to the melanoma
Research Alliance itself which really
helps to set the context for the
approach from which I'm coming to
today's presentation the melanoma
Research Alliance where Mr a was founded
in 2007 with the generous support of
Deborah black and Leon black we were
established under the auspices of the
Milken Institute which is a
philanthropic think tank that has really
helped to launch our startup in a very
fast way as Brenda mentioned our mission
is to accelerate the pace of scientific
discovery to eliminate melanoma
suffering and death we are the largest
private funder of melanoma research and
have been able to invest nearly sixty
eight million dollars in the research
since our first grant went out of the
door in 2008 in this coming grant cycle
we expect to award an additional ten
million dollars to support the research
our focus is on translational research
we have a particular emphasis on teams
as well as early career individuals and
other individual investigators and about
eighty-five percent of our funding is
focused on treatment related melanoma
research with the remainder in
prevention and early diagnostic studies
now moving on into the body of the
presentation the agenda is shown here
and you'll see we come back to this from
time to time as we go through just to
orient us during the presentation I
wanted to just give a quick overview of
the biology of melanoma and how
melanomas form wanted to spend then some
time on both the separate subjects of
targeted therapy for melanoma as well as
immunotherapy and at the very end just
wrap up with some brief commentary on
the future directions in the disease so
now to move into the melanoma overview
melanoma as you may or may not know is
the deadliest of the skin cancers and
unlike a lot of cancers instance is
rising in the US the median diagnosis
for melanoma is at age 62 however in a
little bit starting ly startlingly it is
the most common cancer in 25 to 29 year
olds it is well-managed if caught early
and that's why there's a lot of emphasis
on prevention and detection related
activities early however if it is
detected later in the disease there is a
very poor five-year survival of about
fifteen percent if detected in stage
four I think what you can see in the
graph on the right hand side of the
screen is that while cases have risen
deaths remained flat but I think what we
will see through the course of this
presentation is with the advent of new
therapies I hope and anticipate that
that the Ark of that death curve will
and in fact start to turn downwards a
little bit more about who gets melanoma
it does have its highest incidents in
fair skinned individuals you can
actually see in the top of this chart
that in the white races there is a bit
more melanoma in males and in females
which is not well understood but there
is a low but detectable rate of
melanomas in folks with darker
complexions as you can see here on this
graph and they tend to get a different
kind of melanoma on different surfaces
that have melanocytes in them and I'll
talk about that momentarily cutaneous
melanoma is depicted here in a variety
of clinical images taken from an
excellent review by Jennifer lo and
David Fisher you can see that melanoma
has different presentations it can occur
in different parts of the body and the
top left a typical superficial spreading
melanoma is shown an email a notic
melanoma in the top middle a nodular
melanoma on the top right and then some
of the ones that tend to be more common
in folks that have a darker complexion
on the lower left the April indigenous
melanoma is 1 equal melanomas occur on
the palms of the hands soles of the feet
and under the fingernails they
are kind of at a steady rate in people
of all complexions as do ocular melanoma
is also known as uveal melanoma which
are shown in this look into the eye on
the lower right so the bottom line here
is well more common in fair skinned
individuals melanoma can occur in any
one and vigilance is extremely important
the next slide I won't go I won't spend
a lot of time on because it is very
detailed I do encourage you to take a
look at the publication in nature which
is an excellent provides an excellent
overview of how melanomas form but
suffice to say as shown in the top
center of this illustration melanoma
starts in melanin producing the pigment
producing cells of the skin known as the
melanocytes and when it occurs it occurs
in a relatively small lesion and then
can progress and grow more deeply as you
can see in the March from stage zero to
stage four left to right on your screen
of course the the deeper the melanoma
the bigger the melanoma the more
aggressive it tends to be in the poor
the outcome for patients so it's again
I'm really emphasizing a prevention but
in particular early detection as an
important part of preventing the
formation of bad melanomas well where
melanomas come from what we know from
the genomics that has been done that is
sequencing of melanoma tumors compared
to the normal tissue of individuals who
have provided those samples is that as
you can see on the far right here
melanoma has the highest mutation rate
of any human cancer and melanoma you
know that's a not necessarily the most
noble distinction for it to have but
it's 10 to 100 times more likely to have
mutations than your run-of-the-mill
human cancer if you look at the lower
right of this screen you can see that
big block of yellow there which
indicates the kinds of mutations that
are prevalent in melanoma the sill
called c 2 t transitions these are a
fingerprint of UV exposure and so if as
you can see then there's a huge amount
of evidence for you
the induced damage in melanoma hence the
reasons for sun safe practices to
decrease this incidence of mutation but
these mutations actually aren't just
while there are a lot of kind of willy
nilly mutations present in melanoma
there are also some hallmarks of
melanoma which provide a toehold for
targets in treating the disease and this
illustration shows the results of
summarizing the top most hits come from
whole exome sequencing w es of 213
melanomas and in this analysis
consistent with what has been seen in
other analyses as shown in the top left
about forty percent sometimes people say
fifty percent it does vary from study to
study about forty percent of melanomas
Harvard what are activating mutations in
brf mutations in the signaling protein
known as b-raf that actually turns on
its function and renders normal control
of the protein disabled these mutations
are quite commonly changes in the valine
to a glutamine v600e that's the v600e
mutation those are the most common but
there are a handful of other mutations
that can be discerned as you sequence
more deeply in melanomas the rest of the
mutations wear red here activating
mutations and blue are in activating
mutations and the proteins that are
indicated the genes that are indicated
show that wrasse mutations are very
common in particular an wrasse seems to
be the target for activating mutations
in melanoma and other pathways that
impinge rest signaling including the GTP
is activating protein nf1 that is in
activating in activated in melanoma
leading to a turn-on of Wrath signaling
other mutations that are prevalent are
things that are involved in other tumor
suppressors such as p53 shown here is
tp53 and p10 and then activating
mutations in the cyclin-cdk axis
illustrated here by the CD cdkn2a
mutation
so some of these mutations as you might
well think then lead one to suggest what
can we interfere with the function of
these proteins and that's really
summarized here in the biology with the
prevalence of b-raf and rasp pathway
mutations it suggests that in certain
melanomas especially those with
activating mutations in these pathways
that a personalized medicine approach
targeting those molecules or signaling
molecules downstream such as MEK or Kirk
and erk is sometimes also known as map
kinase or map k that kind of
personalized medicine approach might
really offer benefit for patients in
addition it's reasonable to think and
seems to be playing out that taking
advantage of an anti-tumor immune
response in melanoma against this wide
array of newly formed antigens so called
neo antigens that arise from the
mutations that are so common in melanoma
is it possible to take advantage of
those to either upregulate or stimulate
a pre-existing immune response and
you'll see that that seems to be
supported by the early biology and may
indeed be playing out with the newer
treatment tools that are available so
now let's move on to the targeted
therapy approach in melanoma I've
already mentioned the rass mcGirk
pathway which is shown here in this
slide going from top to bottom you can
see that the the wrasse wrasse is really
the topmost signaling molecule in this
pathway and then it signals through raf
and on into mech and then down into urk
there are molecules that have been
developed to to target each of these
parts of this signaling pathway and this
includes vemurafenib de BRAF a nib to
target b-raf trim attentive and now Kobe
metonym to target mech and then newer
agents that are being explored in the
pipeline that are aimed at the irk part
of the of the pathway there are an in
fact have been in a number of regulatory
approvals both in the US and abroad them
you're a fan dib
dobrze anub tremendum the combination of
de branded intrumental him as well as
and these are all approved in the US as
well as the combination of them your
affidavit and Kobe metonym which was
approved in Switzerland and I think we
can reasonably expect that it will gain
approvals elsewhere in the world in the
near future so these are all agents that
seemed to work to disrupt signaling down
this pathway that occurs due to the
dysregulated mutational status of these
in these tumors so let me talk for a
little bit now about how targeted
therapy agents act when they're applied
as individual drugs as single agents so
very often have been de rafa nib like
other agents that are targeted at this
particular pathway require a diagnostic
test to detect the presence of these six
hundred mutations and in fact in the US
are approved only for the treatment of
the v600e melanomas and in addition the
what one sees when you use these drugs
in patients who have really pretty
significant metastatic burden that there
is a strong response rate about 50%
response rate and the individuals in the
review at the bottom had used the
expression dramatic to describe the
kinds of responses that are seen I think
you probably can appreciate that
oncologists are not the most outspoken
bunch they're not the most of use of
bunch but it really is true patients I
can think of one young woman in
particular who had essentially been
placed in hospice was found to have been
eligible for treatment with these agents
and she really went did undergo one of
these dramatic responses essentially
being well enough to be up and around in
attending things and so these drugs can
really be a miracle for some patients
the side effects are manageable they do
include kind of the activation of other
cancers there are other side effects
associated with these and of course with
all of these drugs but I would say in
general they're not what you think of as
your typical chemotherapy side effects
another approach beyond targeting be
raft is to use the mac
hibbett recommended because it's a
little bit downstream of the RAF it
sweeps in another mutated isoform of
beer at the v600 k mutation and but it
too requires a diagnostic test to be
used per the label in the US as I hinted
at there is a paradoxical activation of
signaling down this pathway in response
to treatment with these agents
unfortunately it's common it may relate
to some of the side effects and nearly
all patients experience progression and
resistance to these agents and one to
two years which means that there's more
to be done and one approach that folks
have taken to be able to try to improve
on these agents is to use them in
combination so b-raf MEK inhibitor
combinations were developed to overcome
the limitations of the single agent
therapies they do have a better response
rate when used in combination they do
come with our own side effects but
interestingly some of the side effects
seem to be mitigated by using the drugs
in combination the combinations that
have been tested have in fact been
tested compared to single agents and so
there's data that shows that dobrze that
have been traumatic summarizes d plus T
is superior to them Europe and abalone
likewise in the separate clinical study
it was shown to be superior to dobrze a
nibble own and in another study the
combination of them you're a fib and the
MEK inhibitor kobe meta nib was also
shown to be superior to them your
operative so I think these these sorts
of combinations definitely do appear to
have legs and newer combinations are
also being explored using rap inhibitors
and MEK inhibitors that may in fact have
slightly different profiles of activity
and one of these is on kuranda than
Benny metonym I have one graph shown
here which really just summarizes what I
said about the data comparing to profit
have been terminated to them you're a
fib this is an overall survival curve
that just simply illustrates that in the
time frame of this particular analysis
the combination of de BRAF inhibitor
metonym was superior to the combination
of them you're a fan of alone and I
think this story plays out for all of
the agents that have been tested in
combination that are be rapin mek
inhibitors compared to be Ralph
inhibitors alone so very encouraging now
just to summarize this particular part
of the presentation on targeted
therapies I have just want to reiterate
I just want to reiterate that me rap and
MEK inhibitors really do offer a truly
personalized medicine strategy for
patients with b-raf mutation in the
combination therapy approaches that have
been tested to date do in fact appear to
be superior to the single agent
approaches and this data is summarized
by this review bio cierto and colleagues
showing a variety of data from the two
phase three studies of drafted and
tremana and memorandum and Kobe metonym
where you can see the overall response
rate is quite good and indeed for DES
branded and tremenda ban the far right
at the top that the median overall
survival was was quite good for that
combination and the data are maturing
for the other agents that are coming
along but nevertheless as i mentioned
resistances is common and most patients
who do get these the rapid mek
inhibitors actually do appear to relapse
and what that means is that for the
field it's very important to be able to
try to identify improved therapeutic
approaches one of which to consider is
immunotherapy and researchers for a long
period of time have been exploring
immunotherapy as a means to improve
mellow melanoma outcomes even more so
now we'll move on to the next part of
the presentation I just want to give you
a couple of slides by way of overview of
the background on immuno therapy so it's
really been known for some time that
immuno that melanoma is one of the more
immuno responsive tumors some of that
has revealed itself by way of tumors
kind of resolving on their own for no
obvious reason and a small fraction a
very small fraction of patients William
B Kohli at the turn of the century tried
to harness this effect by using
infections to target cancers including
melanoma in the late 1990s high-dose
il-2 a cytokine that stimulates the
immune system was approved by the FDA
for the treatment of melanoma and in
2011 interferon alfa-2b was approved for
the treatment of melanoma after
successful surgery to resect the cancer
so both of these cytokines have been
used to stimulate the immune system to
take advantage of its ability to mop up
melanomas however both of these agents
and indeed including the approach that
dr. Coley took are associated with
significant dose-related toxicities and
a relatively low response rate so these
observations both spurred the search for
better approaches because because there
are hints of success but there was
really limited activity with acceptable
toxicity and the next two slides really
just allow us to focus a bit on some of
the more contemporary approaches to
immunotherapy that are being used today
I will spend most of my time during the
rest of the presentation focusing on the
right-hand part of this slide talking
about the monoclonal antibodies that are
being used to disrupt these checkpoints
signaling molecules that are still
illustrated here ctla-4 pd-1 and PDL one
but I do want to say that there are
other approaches that are being explored
in the clinic that I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on except in the
future therapies section that are trying
to take advantage of other immune cells
beyond the T cells which are of course
central in the response against the
tumor cells but I also will just mention
that there are a number of vaccines that
are being developed which take advantage
of the fact that peptides or other
approaches can stimulate then
dendritic cells and these dendritic
cells then go on to present appropriate
antigens to t cells for further activity
likewise there's a lot of activity in
the area of cellular immunotherapy where
tumor cells excuse me t cells or
dendritic cells may be isolated from a
patient and then manipulated outside of
the body in a variety of ways re
administered to the patient and the and
all in the hopes that they've been
enriched and activated to essentially
mop up the tumor cells and do away with
them taking advantage of the immune
system but as I said I will focus mostly
on checkpoint blockade so-called
checkpoint blockade which is mainly
built around three approved agents right
now the first of these is the anti
ctla-4 antibody known as a polymer mAb
whose trade name is your voi the anti
pd-1 drugs are the newest players in
this in this area they are pemberley's
I'm AB also known as key Truda and
nivolumab whose trade name is OP Devo
and so what's the general mechanism of
action for these agents tumor cells and
other cells appear to upregulate
signaling to the t-cells that turns them
off and that signaling is mediated in
part by PDL one it also is accepted by
the t-cell we're recognized by the T
cell as a turn off signal through
molecules on its cell surface called
ctla4 and pd1 and so the idea behind
these antibodies is that they would come
in block the block the ctla4 or block
the pd-1 signal and therefore turn down
the deregulation that's why it's
checkpoint blockade kind of a kind of a
double negative two then we activate the
immune systems in particular the T cells
ability to attack the tumor so
checkpoint blockade in in summary has
three main tools that are approved right
now if a limo map targeting CTL
for member lism ab and nivolumab each
targeting pd1 what do we know about
implement map so if amanda bab was the
first of these agents to be approved it
was approved in 2011 based on a look at
the long-term data out to ten years
really you see 120 months the that about
twenty percent of patients treated with
Ebola mab appear to experience durable
responses that are sustained for as long
as ten years it the curve seems to start
to flatten out around three years and
this is really exciting because these
are these are not just any patients
these are patients with advanced
metastatic melanoma who had no other
options who otherwise had an extremely
short lifespan ahead of them and so this
is really a market improvement in the
landscape for melanoma treatment and
demonstrated long-term survival starts
to make people think about using the
cure word which is really exciting in
oncology especially in melanoma / which
there were no treatments of widespread
usage and significant approved in many
decades really until Ethel Emma mAb and
vemurafenib the targeted therapy
inhibitor were approved in 2011 but um
that you know let me just bounce back
for a second you know twenty percent of
patients one in five I mean it's great
but it's really not as good as we want
things to be of course so a number of
activities have been taken to try to
improve on the circumstances for
melanoma melanoma I have it here as
improving on at the lemon map it's
really just improving for patients in
general but I millis trading here the
outcomes for patients treated with the
first anti pd-1 drug that was approved
in the US pember lism ab it has been
studied on a couple of schedules and
every three weeks schedule as well as in
every two weeks schedule let me just
first point out that is you you look at
these two schedules in comparison
there's really not a big difference
between them the every three weeks
schedule is the one that is FDA approved
and that's how
pember lism a drupe embryo is
administered and in this particular
study in which the authors looked at
overall survival you can see that pember
lism abbas a single agent didn't appear
to offer superior overall survival
outcomes in patients when used as a
single agent similar data have been seen
with nivolumab alone so that's seems to
be just a feature of anti pd-1
antibodies which is really fantastic
news for patients well what about
nivolumab alone or nivolumab and if a
luma map in combination right because
when we have useful tools in the
oncology business one of the typical
things to do is to provide studies of
these agents in combination and there's
there's good preclinical biology that
suggests that the different activities
of anti pd-1 antibodies as compared to
aunty ctla-4 antibodies might well
indicate a superior benefit by bringing
the two together so in a study that also
that examined nivolumab as a single
agent that's the blue line ap and nivo
nivolumab a nipple Emma map in
combination that's the orange line but
both compared to iffy in the same study
it did appear that certainly neva was
superior to it be and that the
combination of the two looked to be at
least as active as the individual agent
nivolumab the authors noted in the
presentation of this data that this
particular study was not powered to
directly compare nebo and it be together
I think while we are looking at
progression-free survival here not
overall survival we will need to wait to
see how the data mature to see if indeed
overall survival is comparable or better
or i guess potentially worse just to
explore all of the outcomes compared to
the IPPY overall survival data but that
will take some time to mature and we are
greatly looking forward to seeing the
outcome of those experiments this is a
so-called swimmers
depicting the positive benefit of it be
an EVO and combination as well as some
of the side effects that are observed
it's a little bit of a complicated slide
but I do want to spend some time on it
because it makes a couple of interesting
points so first of all as you can see
grade 3 and 4 adverse events were
observed in a number of patients
actually about half of the patients
experienced one of these significant
grade 3-4 adverse events as compared to
apple Emma mAb which was about twenty
four percent and it's interesting most
people I guess in the old days back in
2011 but if he was pretty tough medicine
so now i think the field has a pretty
good handle certainly at the academic
medical centers where there's
significant experience would they be how
to mitigate the side effects there and I
as as it gains experience I imagine they
will learn how to also more productively
manage the significant side effects
associated with the combination of a
peon evo but even though half of
patients discontinued treatment due to
the side effects in the combination
we're just going to point out in the
swimmers plot so every black arrow is a
place where a patient would had an
ongoing response so you can see there's
a large number of ongoing responses you
know out to almost a year in this
particular study and that many of those
responses are sustained for example in
this region even after discontinuing
therapy the responses which kind of
occur down here occur early in this
treatment and are sustained even after
treatment discontinuation so this is
actually pretty remarkable a pretty
remarkable observation and I think bodes
well for the activity of the combination
especially for people who might not want
to get a lot of pretty tough combination
therapy I think it's really really very
encouraging data another piece of I
guess I would say both encouraging and
perhaps cautionary data
is illustrated by this case report that
was published in the new england journal
of medicine that showed that in a
particular patient who had a large mass
in the chest wall you can see it here in
the CT scan you can see it here visibly
in this picture looking up on her body
that she had this really large
metastatic melanoma tumor within six
weeks of receiving the combination
therapy the tumor kind of cavitating
went away and you can see the resolution
of it here so um this is again a
pictures always worth a thousand words
fantastic news for the power of these
agents in combination but also was
published as a case report by the
authors as a cautionary tale because one
can well imagine that if such a
resolution occurred in an important
internal organ there might be side
effects that would need to be managed
quite aggressively in in the case that
such activity were observed so we're at
we've actually moved through the
presentation at quite a good rate and I
want to just spend a few minutes on this
particular slide to talk a little bit
about what's what's happening in the
melanoma field right now by way of
summary as it relates to treatments and
to show yet another illustration of
active immunotherapy and melanoma so
really the title of the presentation is
reiterated here melanoma is a case study
for both targeted therapy and
immunotherapy in this disease there have
been a series of tremendous approvals
for melanoma starting in 2011 with the
approval of em you're a fan abbr and
trim attentive which is active and
approved in v600e melanoma beginning in
2013 we saw the approval of de bravo nib
and traumatic for bibra v600e and
traumatic for either v600e or v 600k
melanoma the combination
giraffe ative intermit anub the first
combination therapy for melanoma was
approved in 2014 for the both targeted
agents so this particular point the
particular point I want to make here is
that new diagnostic tests are required
and used to treat melanoma patients in a
very personalized way with these
targeted therapy agents in the realm of
immunotherapy we see that if lemma mAb
the an anti ctla4 antibody was approved
in 2011 and the activity of apollomon
lab in an early paper published in 2010
is illustrated at the right hand part of
the screen so this particular patient
you can see had a large series of
melanoma metastasis on the skin within a
short period of time after getting a
polymer mAb there was what appeared to
be a worsening of disease this is
sometimes referred to as pseudo
progression it is occasionally seen with
immunotherapy fortunately the
investigators were able to treat through
this apparent progression on the
immunotherapy and now you can see in
these lower panels but as time goes on
this individuals melanoma did resolve so
this is a little bit of an unheard-of
observation in oncology treatment and it
just illustrates the different kinds of
responses that immunotherapies can
elicit the responses can be time delayed
and so there is a reason to think that
patients was with extremely aggressive
disease may not be the ones to benefit
as rapidly as one would observe though
the combination approaches seemed to
work fairly much more quickly than it'll
in mab so now coming back to the summary
the anti pd-1 antibodies pember lism AB
and Ebola mAb were approved in 2014 with
PEM broking the first anti pd-1 antibody
approved in the US neva was actually
approved in Japan earlier in 2014 so it
was the first anti pd-1 antibody
approved anywhere in the world and I'm
extremely excited to be able to tell you
today that the news was announced just
this morning that the combination of
nivolumab in diplomat a regimen for the
treatment of metastatic metastatic
melanoma was approved by the FDA today
it is the first combination
immunotherapy approval anywhere in the
world it came for patients who have no
mutations at position 600 in brf so
called BF v600 wild-type disease but
really hot breaking news and and just
goes to show how quickly this field is
moving what I've summarized on the next
slide for those of you who are curious
about keeping track of things and also
curious about what are the little what's
a little more of the biology behind
these treatments is a summary of the
melanoma approvals from bottom to top
from oldest to most recent and also the
indicator of how quickly the FDA dealt
with them I think what you can see is
that the FDA has really done a great job
to employ all of the tools available to
it from fast-track approval Priority
Review accelerated approval and the
latest tool in his toolbox breakthrough
therapy designation to really work
closely with the developers in a
back-and-forth conversation to be able
to bring agents through to patients in
an extremely fast way hembra was member
was approved in September 2014 nivo in
December 2014 and here less than a year
later we have a combination approval for
AP and Nebo and really really fantastic
news for patients the different styles
of antibodies and whether they're small
molecules or combination therapies are
summarized here it's it's really a new
era for melanoma patients with with
these agents coming to the fore so where
does that leave us and where are we
going from here is a field this
particular slide
comes two comes to us courtesy of
michael Atkins who provided this review
at the 2015 ASCO meeting after the
plenary session which talked about some
of the data on the anti pd-1 anti ctla-4
combination and what you can see on the
bottom is that the field march is on as
I've mentioned before from single agent
to combination approvals with
vemurafenib as the first agent approved
and now data emerging showing that these
agents are really superior in
combination then in the initial approval
of it the limit map in 2011 that showing
that it was superior to a vaccine to
where we are and indeed to where we find
ourselves today with it be an EVO being
approved based on the data that was
submitted to the FDA and maybe 600
wild-type disease disease and I think
this out this pending question of
whether the combination is in fact
superior to a single agent disease and I
think we all eagerly await seeing what
the data look like as the overall
survival data matures and so this is
really my last slide just talking about
from dr. Atkins perspective that PT 1 is
probably the backbone therapy for
melanoma treatment and it acts in it
acts in the tumor to really turn the
breaks off on the immune system you can
see these little blue dots here
illustrating the T cells that have been
in that invade the tumor in orbit sparse
but are probably turned off by the tumor
and so antibodies against pd1 newer
antibodies that are coming along
targeting anti PDL targeting PDL one are
aimed at making these T cells more
effective in their micro environment but
there are quite a lot of tumors in
particular in melanoma but even in other
cancers that have really physically
excluded the T cells from the tumor you
kind of see a front of t cells that are
they almost look like there's some kind
of barrier to them from entering
tumor and this appears to be where
agents that are like at the limo mab the
ctla4 targeting antibody or potentially
other ways to energize the immune system
and bring those t-cells into the tumor
like immune activating antibodies or
cytokines toll receptor agonists perhaps
oncolytic viruses which are also moving
through the regulatory review paradigm
or maybe even the targeted therapies
might actually stimulate further
invasion of the T cells into the tumor
so I think this is the the ability to
modulate the activity of the immune
system has really opened up a lot of
opportunities for melanoma patients but
also for many cancer patients and then
finally the last approach which just
gets a lot of enthusiasm because it does
appear that for some patients this
really seems to work well in melanoma is
the opportunity to produce t-cells to
generate T cells that have particular
activities or are enriched for the their
ability to attack the melanoma this
could take place by either the
development of therapeutic vaccines not
just the kinds of vaccines you're used
to hearing about perhaps that are used
to prevent disease but are actually used
to treat the melanoma that is
pre-existing there is a lot of work that
is going on especially in other fields
in the blood cancer area in particular
to use T cell receptor engineered
adoptive cell therapy that's the TCR
engineered adoptive cell therapy or
chimeric antigen receptors another way
to engineer specificity into T cells as
as the way to approach producing a
productive immune response against
melanoma and indeed as I said in other
cancers the cd19 cars for example look
particularly promising and then
stereotactic radiation as well as
chemotherapy
or to be a potential way to enhance the
immunotherapeutic response but I do want
to talk from just one moment before I
wrap up about chemo in melanoma there
have been a large number of studies
published recently that clearly
demonstrate that immunotherapy is far
superior to chemotherapy and so
chemotherapy and melanoma is really
relegated to I really i would say
desperate situations and not a treatment
of choice for melanoma based on the
positive data that we've seen in the
clinical trials to date well that takes
me to the end of my presentation my
contact information is shown here and i
do want to definitely point you to our
website which is shown at the bottom
pure melanoma org has some information
not only on our research activities but
also information on patients on these
cutting-edge treatments now that we have
nine new therapies that have been
produced we'll be updating that
information as of today it's been a
pleasure to present to you and i'm happy
to take any questions
any questions from those of you out
there I put a question out there maybe
just to get conversation started to have
any of you been treated with either
melanoma targeted therapy or
immunotherapy Thank You Louise Thank You
Louise for that informative presentation
I'm just going to remind our audience
how they can start their questions they
can submit questions by typing them into
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green QA button the
lower left of the presentation window
will try to answer as many questions as
we can in addition I want to let our
audience know that this presentation has
been approved for continuing educational
credits you want to obtain the credit
please click on you get your free cm ECE
credits button located in the lower left
of your screen this will take you to a
page listing all of our speakers and
presentations and you can claim your
certificate at that point we do have one
question with respect to meta tastic
melanoma and new immunotherapies how was
the frequency of mutations valine what
and s-100 levels did any patients have
sickle cell disease so this is an
interesting this is an interesting
question let me comment on two different
aspects of it the frequency of mutations
observed in melanoma was really
discovered based on the high-throughput
sequencing that's been enabled by a lot
of the genomic technologies that have
been used for many years and in some
ways actually kind of got a bad rap
recently that it's not going to help
anyone in fact that data is proving to
be critical in our understanding and
ability to take advantage of what's
going on in disease i must say i don't
know about the relationship between
those levels and s-100 nor do i know
about any relationship to sickle cell
disease
I guess I would say one thing however
since sickle cell is more common in
patients at least in the u.s. of african
american descent and since melanoma is
relatively uncommon there my guess is
that there's not a clear linkage but i
don't know that for a fact that's a
that's a very interesting point there's
another question that has come in any
successes yet in using a DC which i
assume is meant as antibody drug
conjugates against melanoma I think the
answer there is that there are a number
of mutations that are excuse me let me
say this differently there are a number
of antigens that are present on melanoma
that appeared to be ones that one might
take get a handle on however some of
those are expressed somewhat widely
throughout the body and in other tissues
and so I think the the impetus has been
to not move aggressively towards
antibody drug conjugates but to actually
focus on maybe the more broadly acting
immune system to treat melanoma another
question another question great
questions coming in from our audience
our next question how important is the
kinase selectivity for small molecule
inhibitors of melanoma targets yeah so
this is a this is an important question
as well the the kind of selectivity is
an interesting question and one to be
sure to keep in mind in any activity
that you're undertaking to try to target
particular protein for example the
inhibitor of MuRF and it actually has a
particular mode of inhibition of v600e
melanoma that is a little bit different
from the inhibitors of de branded
informative now these drugs in general
are reasonably so
elective kinase inhibitors another drug
that was originally thought to be a an
inhibitor of RAF kinase was sera phanom
and I was actually at there at the time
that Sarafina was being developed it is
a b-raf inhibitor but it does become
pick up a broad spectrum of other
kinases in its in its inhibitory profile
and I think what's believed now is that
in general the activity of that agent is
probably mediated more strongly through
inhibition of kdr veg fr2 but not so
much through b-raf so I think of the in
the case of the approved drugs for be
wrapped in particular to Brandon and Ben
me Raph nib as well as trementina the
mek inhibitor I think the specificity of
those molecules is reasonably good and
we're in good shape on that front
thank you for that answer our next
question has come in from the audience
how how is the cost of small molecules
versus immunotherapy does it justify the
superiority of the immunotherapy so the
the cost question is an important one
it's an important one here in the US and
it's an important one around the world I
think what we're really looking at is a
revolution in how we think about
treating cancer indeed if you're talking
about patients who might be able to get
a relatively short course of
immunotherapy and then potentially have
an enduring response I think that the
the benefits of that may well play out
as we see that data mature the relative
cost of targeted therapy versus
immunotherapy since we know that I think
they I think it's a little bit of apples
and oranges we know that targeted
therapy offers benefits for patients who
have extensive disease that is really
out of control and it really offers them
a chance to have some high quality time
ahead of them and indeed there are some
patients who appear to have really long
term responses although it's a small
fraction but really long term responses
with targeted therapy I think as we will
see with the immunotherapies it may be
that these immunotherapies kind of
amount to a sort of well if we're lucky
let me put it this way if we're lucky
they amount to a kind of molecular
surgery that is able to elicit a
long-term response i think the cost
question is one that's really critical
around the world at the melanoma
Research Alliance we are particularly
interested in making sure that new
treatments and new innovations are
available for patients and I think
really focused on driving those
innovations forward while letting those
who are expert in the cost equation try
to work out the authority details of
that particular
Challenge wait our next question have
you tried Optima as a Ras b-raf
inhibitor of graphene melanoma so I
haven't seen any data on the use of apt
immerses inhibitors I seem to recall
there was some old work that was done
but I just haven't seen anything done
recently you know I must say there the
targeted therapies really do offer a lot
of benefit and so at the melanoma
Research Alliance about forty percent of
our funding portfolio is invested in
trying to drive an understanding of how
to improve on these therapies so if the
research shows that apt numbers offer
some unique therapeutic benefit
especially in overcoming the resistance
that develops I would encourage all
kinds of research down that pathway to
be explored
Brenda do you want to feel take a look
at those next questions yes thank you
for these we do have one more question
is the immune system activity and met
assess patients lower than normal
naturally this is a this is a really
complex argument and I think where
there's a need for a lot of a lot of
research to take place you have to
remember that the immune system is a
particularly complicated beasty there
are many different cells some of which
are involved in being the the attackers
the warriors on the ground to take to
kill cells that are foreign or to
release agents like antibodies that can
manage foreign antigens there are also
cells of the immune system that are
involved in turning off an immune
response so that one doesn't just become
one great big lymph node and I think
what the research is starting to suggest
is that in some cases and and you could
even think of it as an overly healthy
immune system is actually a disadvantage
because it's somehow turning off an
anti-tumor immune response but I think
in general the the more prevailing
perception is that a less robust immune
system may indeed lead to less robust
antitumor immune responses I guess I
would just wrap all of that up by saying
for patients it's important to just take
care of yourself and try to live as
healthy a lifestyle as possible without
going to extreme lengths
anything else for us Brenda
Thank You Louise that is all the time
that we have for questions yet I just
want to ask if you have any final
comments vice or other information for
our audience I just want to say that
it's really been a great pleasure to be
able to present to you today I hope
you've found the information very
helpful I would say if any of you are
patients who are patient family members
or caregivers I would encourage you
strongly to seek out the input and
advice of melanoma nonprofits who are
well-connected in the field there's a
lot of things that are moving very
quickly in the melanoma business and
it's a little bit hard for the docs to
keep up with it I think unless you see
melanomas every day in which case it's a
different story of course the other
thing I would say is that melanoma
indeed really is proving to be a case
study for other cancers there are as
many as 10 cancers that are being
aggressively studied based on the timely
results that are coming from work on
checkpoint blockade and biomarker work
which I didn't touch on at all that's
being funded by ourselves and by others
so the work in melanoma is really
floating all boats in real time to
advance the field for cancer care across
the board it's an extremely exciting
time in cancer as I said and I thank you
for your attention
Thank You Louise and I'd like to thank
our audience for their time and
attention as well today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2016 you'll receive an
email from lab units alerting you when
that webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward down
announcement to any colleagues whom I've
missed today's live event thank you
again for attending we hope to see you
next time goodbye